say you're stuck in the Mojave Desert
and you need a ride to Las Vegas and say
you're picky if you don't want to arrive
in Sin City and any old Honda well if
you're like me you call a friend one who
happens to have his very own homemade
self-driving car
problem solved they're a couple miles
out of Barstow and acid kicked him where
hunter s Thompson had dr. gonzo as a
companion I have this guy George Hotz he
comes with less drugs the plenty of fear
and loathing hots became famous as a
teenager for hacking everything in sight
he hacked the iPhone he hacked the Sony
Playstation he has the legal fees to
prove it
and now he's hacking cars he stunned the
world last year by building this
self-driving car by himself in a San
Francisco garage in just a couple of
months they visited him back then to see
his Acura packed full of cameras radars
and artificial intelligence software
unlike the Tesla's and Google's of the
world Potts doesn't give his car a
litany of rules to follow he basically
just drives the thing and the car learns
to mimic the behavior and does so better
and better over time don't cross the
exit I'll do it I know you want to I
know you want to I know you see that
exit oh good job car Hots hasn't bested
night writer yet but he has achieved
Hasselhoff s heights of confidence
meanwhile back on the road to Vegas soon
we'll probably be able to drive without
radar just using the camera just using a
camera and cameras like our cell phone
that camera is good enough to drive the
car
I could keep bashing everyone like I'm
the underdog but am I really the
underdog I have a working self-driving
car but everyone appreciates Hutt's
unique brand of gusto the California DMV
for example recently told hots to quit
driving his experiment on the state's
roads this is why we've had to head to
the Nevada border where the true freedom
of the Mojave lives on we're getting
close to the border reporter I'll press
the button once we hit the border why
can't we do it in California they don't
like innovation Nevada loves innovation
that's what I heard oh I see the sign I
see you son prepare to engage
I'm on your command captain alright here
we go
welcome to Nevada 3 the Silver State to
one your self-drive houses car had never
seen that Avada roads before but it
drove perfectly on its own for miles
that is until the Desert Sun dipped down
casting shadows across the road there's
actually a worse time of day for it the
contrast is not very good as the Sun is
so bright still and the road is so dim
and look you see now no no can't drive
Wow good I can't see anything in the
picture
this is really bad what does make you
think is this something you can fix over
time a lot of this has to do with the
camera a lot of the bug right now is
just cuz the camera can't say as we
finally made our way onto the Vegas
Strip I tried to cheer him up well let's
just see what happens it might go too
soon it might go too soon oh no it sees
them there it sees them there ya go car
go here we go
don't hit the fan don't hit the fan
that's closer than a shed of god that's
his car passed the test and his
existential angst lifted the legend of
dr. hots lives on feeling better now
yeah that's good that's good full
autonomy haven't disengaged